did you see the statistics on how many
times we touch our face in a day
we just are faced about a hundred times
a day yeah and that's the access point
okay your eyes your nose your mouth so
if there's a a virus on a surface you
just touched and then you and it'll stay
alive on your hand and then you touch
your face you got it so that's why
washing the hands is good not only so
that when you touch your face you can
minimize the chance of you infecting
yourself you minimize the chance of you
infecting someone else by other surfaces
that you touch so well here's what I
hope I hope and by the way what is hope
it's what you want to be true knowing
you're not entirely in control yeah okay
like hope and prayer both of those
similar but so let me say it's more than
a hope here's my expectation if people
listen to scientists and medical
professionals and do exactly what we all
say maybe the coronavirus will not have
a place to thrive because we're taking
it out at every turn at the doorknobs at
the kitchen counters in the back we just
taken it out it's trying and we're not
giving it that chance and then it
lightly washes over the country
disappears and never to return now we
would have kicked the corona virus ass
as far as you know I get asked a lot
about supplements and stuff and I saw
some people are asking questions about
supplements I think at this point you
know there's reasonable evidence that
zinc is probably worth taking the
challenge of course is in what format so
zinc is not necessarily the most
bioavailable thing depending on how you
take it
but you know you're generally going to
need about I don't know call it you know
30 to 50 milligrams of a relatively
bioavailable zinc the lozenges which are
typically pretty good have been kind of
sold out on Amazon for quite some time
so you know saying supplementation
probably makes a little bit of sense you
know as far as anything else I think
it's just too hard to say and my concern
with it is I wouldn't want to give
somebody a false sense of confidence
that because they're taking you know
vitamin C or vitamin D which also
probably quite important especially if
you can't get out into sunlight so you
know people who live in parts of the
country or the world where they can
still despite a quarantine get out and
get sunshine I think that's hugely
important to get vitamin D in the
natural way if people can't then I think
supplementing vitamin D would also
matter but again you just don't want
people to think that that protects them
from washing their hands and things like
that yeah and of course distancing from
you know people who themselves are not
able to quarantine the diffuser and I
mean every day
tea tree oil this is so important to
tree honors antiviral and antibacterial
so every day Fitness little thing I just
switch it on on my burn teacher or
eucalyptus and peppermint is one in my
kitchen have this one in my bedroom is
where I can set to go off after six
hours and I burn them all day because I
want to help my lungs I want to help my
chest and even smoke this if you feel a
bit congested you can put a tiny drop
just one tiny drop in water and drink it
but if you've got a family at home this
is so good for the airf it's what your
children are breathing in so tea tree
oil is amazing
get it while you still can happen at
least it doesn't matter just take a
little bowl of water put in 15
listen put it on your radiator you can
actually put it straight on to a
radiator because the heat will diffuse
the oil that a bowl of water is a great
thing if you have a fire you can have it
near fire there's lots of ways you can
do this you can even just boil the
kettle and have it in little bowls you
can put it on the stove you don't have a
radiators in your house put it on the
stove and just simmer lists and for a
couple of hours every day so I'm a big
fan of boards I also think this is great
tcp oil all of us oil i love if you have
any symptoms like headaches and sniffles
it's a great thing to just smooth this
rub it on your head and heat if you feel
anything in your chest put a hot water
bottle on your chest use some vapor rub
so this is one of my key lines you know
the problem with this virus as there is
no vaccine there aren't any medications
that we can really take apart from the
obvious paracetamol but this is my
favorite thing to take secondly i'm
gonna really recommend that you take
supplements i'm gonna tell you the key
ones and these are really really
important not only now when the virus is
around that even when the virus is gone
back to normal what can you do to stop
yourself getting a weak immune system
well you want to take some supplements
you want to take vitamin d and you want
to take 5,000 IU's that means
international units that's a lot if you
read different and furious different
recommendations i say 400 800 up to
5,000 in these times start at 5
5,000 iron use that is Mindy a thousand
of sea I don't love this brand of it
women see because it's sort of sugar I
like these ones that you put in water
that you ingest they're much better but
honestly at the moment any vitamins
better than no toxins and zinc this is
so important for colds for viruses you
always want to take the zinc and you
want to take about 50 milligrams of zinc
a day that may seem a lot you see when
you look at the recommended dose for any
supplements or vitamins that's recommend
for someone who is eating well is not
stressed and isn't living a world of
pollution if you're stressed or kind of
stressed right now
you're not eating well if you're around
pollutants you need more so I would
really recommend you take a lot
virtually every day again lots of lots
of emails and lots of lots of comments
how do i boost my immune system people
are asking how do I increase my immunity
to reduce my chances of getting the
covered 19 virus or of getting it less
severely and as I understand it I don't
know of any way to boost your immune
system
but I do know of lots of way to make
what lots of ways to make it worse so
the human immune system is quite an
amazing thing it can recognize something
like 9 billion foreign antigens things
that the body would recognize as foreign
bacteria and viruses quite an amazing
system and I don't know have a way to
boost it but and there are plenty ways
to make it work less optimally to reduce
the efficiency of it but of course
remember this copied 19 is a novel virus
it hasn't been seen before so the immune
system is not going to recognize it and
it's going to have to start making its
antibodies it's gonna have to start the
immunological process from scratch so
how do I get my immune system to be as
good as it can be is the real question
so you can't boost immunity but you can
make it worse so how do you make it as
good as we can make it well the first
thing is make sure you get plenty of
sleep lack of sleep will be due
immunity so good sleep is important the
second point is make sure you are well
nourished now people talk about taking
lots of this nutrient or loss of that
nutrient or eating lots of that to give
protective effects and the evidence for
that really is not strong if it's there
at all
so I would say get plenty of good
nutrition so we want lots of plant
products lots of flavonoids five annoyed
czar in the colored components of plants
so lots of fresh nutrients as much as
you know lots of fresh fruit and
vegetables enough protein we don't need
to eat masses of protein we don't need
huge amounts of protein but we need
enough protein
now the nutrient that we're often short
of in the Northern Hemisphere's is
vitamin D so I'm currently taking a
vitamin D supplement that's the only
supplement I'm taking at the moment just
vitamin D because that's the only one
I'm likely to be short of so by taking
huge amounts of extra nutrients I'm not
going to boost my immune system but by
being low on any nutrient I can reduce
the efficiency of my immune system and
because there's no sunshine over English
winters I take vitamin D because my skin
won't make it and we know that vitamin D
deficiency is associated with immune
deficiency so nutrition is one thing but
no evidence for these fads that should
eat lots and lots of garlic or lots and
lots of vitamin C don't be short of
these things I mean garlic is good for
you anyway and it's got plant flavonoids
and nutrients in it so is good but
taking huge amounts of it as I
understand it will not boost the immune
system because I don't think it's
possible to boost the immune system it's
only possible to keep working at its
normal healthy optimum level now
psychological stress can reduce immune
function so try and try and reduce your
stress that's the ludicrous thing to say
I'm not quite sure how you do that but
but but try and reduce stress as much as
you can
socializing and sharing things is
probably one of the best ways to do that
do keep 50 of you can exercise is good
regular exercise is good because these
things optimize health and if you
optimize health you're likely to
optimize immunity get plenty of fresh
air
good ventilation I think is important
how is Kovac 19 different from the flu
in terms of you know how it you know in
a rash to the body and just how it
spreads well it's similar in some
respects step in that it's a respiratory
illness that's transmitted by the
respiratory route it gives a degree of
pathology that's mostly pneumonia the
reason it's different is that it's very
very much more transmissible than flu
and more importantly it's significantly
more serious let me give you some very
quick numbers okay burrow mortality of
seasonal flu that you and I confront
every year is about 0.1% the overall
mortality of coronavirus is about 1%
sometimes like in China it was up to 2
to 3% which means it's at least ten
times more serious than the typical
influenza so when people kind of compare
it in some respects in as some
similarities but it's really really
different in its degree of seriousness
and is that I know they've been hearing
a lot of kind of rumors around our
numbers around from you know when I
showed up in China to other different
countries you know the disparity or
discrepancy amongst ages and how it
affects obviously underlining underlying
health conditions or you know if you're
a little older that it affects you a
little bit more seriously but as that's
shown differently here in the states in
terms of you know different age brackets
and and just the severity of you know
the cases of death versus air units and
and all those type of things yeah mostly
the same but with some interesting may
be disturbing differences if you look at
China you look at Europe you look at
South Korea it predominantly is
reasonably benign if you want to call it
that you get sick but you don't get into
serious trouble if you're young
very heavily weighted towards the
elderly and those with underlying
conditions
heart disease lung disease diabetes
kidney disease those are the people who
have a higher degree of mortality we
know that for sure we're seeing that a
lot of now in the United States but what
we are starting to see is that there are
some people who are younger people your
age young healthy vigorous who don't
have any underlying conditions who are
getting seriously ill it's still a very
very small minority but it doesn't mean
that young people like yourself should
say I'm completely exempt from any risk
of getting seriously ill and that's the
reason why we talk about being careful a
physical distancing doing the kind of
social separation it means not only for
the elderly but the young people have to
do with two for two reasons one you need
to protect yourself because you're not
completely exempt from serious illness
but do you can become the vector or the
carrier of infection well you get
infected you feel well and then you
inadvertently and innocently pass it on
to your grandfather your grandmother or
uncle who's on chemotherapy for cancer
that's what we got to be careful of if
you want more advice wisdom guidance
from other successful entrepreneurs on
how you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable continue to believe and I'll
see you there I think what would be nice
to go is if we can cooking can be
therapy